[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to City
skylines 2 and welcome back to St Luke
in today's episode I'm doing something
which is uh probably a little bit too
ambitious um so spoilers already I'm not
going to be uh able to finish what I've
started in this episode but then again
it's a it's a little much to be honest
for uh this episode we are allowed to go
up to uh one of the later milestones in
the game um and actually go for I think
it is a big city already um whichever
Milestone it was it's quite far and
we're also allowed to have videos of up
to an hour long um which is all right I
think if you're mostly playing the game
live and trying to commentate along the
way and see what kind of things you can
build uh but in my case I'm still trying
to timelapse everything to just about
the same speed as the last few episodes
so in the end that means that I have
somewhere between 7 and 8 hours of
recording in this video already and I
was nowhere near finished to the level
that I was hoping to be which I I guess
is kind of like U Hof stutters law I
don't know if any of you guys have ever
heard of hutter's law but it basically
means that anything you want to do is
going to end up taking longer than you
think it's going to take even taking
into account Hof stutters law uh so it's
just kind of a fun self- referential
thing there um but that's totally what
ended up happening here even taking this
into account I figured I could at least
kind of finish uh what I started out
doing here but no way um basically I'm
trying to build a well small to
mediumsized City including an old city
center some 19th century neighborhoods
around it and all kinds of suburbs and
I'm not sure what it's going to be
called yet so if you guys want to give
name suggestions you're very welcome I
know I liked using the generator on the
last episode but also in the comments
you guys came up with really great name
ideas so I'm still open for suggestions
as well um but basically I'm trying to
build a big city here the city on the uh
Mainland uh across the water from St
Luke and the idea is that it's a kind of
port City and for my inspiration here I
went to a different region whereas most
of St Luke itself is inspired by uh
Plymouth and that area in the south of
England um I went in a whole another
Direction uh for inspiration for this
city and kind of looked at the area of
Newcastle um just kind of happened
because well this is a port city and I
was looking for mediumsized port cities
in the UK and how they tend to develop
um so it was just a a fun uh way to uh
to reference something for this build
now in terms of the order in which I'm
doing things I'm not completely doing
things in a chronological sort of sense
like I said with St Luke um I think it's
a usually the best idea to kind of
chronologically work your way from older
ages to newer ages and you sort of
organically get a city that looks like
it's organically grown over time you
know you want to start off with some
rural Fields uh make a basic rural
looking layout and then you want to
start uh filling in the old city center
and growing neighborhoods around that in
the same shape that your old uh rural
Fields were and generally that way you
end up getting a pretty organic City and
then once you start adding railroads and
highways and stuff like that you really
have to move your way around some of the
older neighborhoods and parks and stuff
like that and that's typically how you
get a city that looks realistic I think
something that ends up happening a lot
when you build cities just kind of from
a flat empty space of land is that
everything just looks a bit too planned
you know the the railroad is very
conveniently placed near the middle of
the city and the The Rail lines are all
very convenient you've got a highway
that doesn't seem to you know have to
move around anything and has perfectly
fine exits and entries and stuff like
that and it results in very nice
functional cities um that are kind of
satisfying to look at in that way I
guess but something which makes cities
kind of real is that they are very messy
and sometimes very you have to shoehorn
some things in um because that's just
how they develop so as much as I would
have liked to take that approach for
this build I think it would have taken
even longer um and it would have also
resulted in this episode being very much
like the past two episodes and then only
from that point onward uh we could
actually start building on it plus I
wouldn't get anywhere near the Milestone
that I'm trying to reach for this video
um so even though I might not actually
reach it in this video either here at
least I'm getting close and at least by
the end of this video we'll have a large
um extent of the city already done to
the extent that I'm planning to finish
it in the next video um so this is
something that I still want to continue
until we have a realistic region that
kind of Blends the urban and rural
together and really make it feel like
you know this city at some point in the
future really has a context with St Luke
on the other side of the water and on
this side of the water having all kinds
of villages and stuff around it um but
yeah in this episode I'm just starting
off with the city center and trying to
figure out how this city could have
grown over time uh while I come up with
Road networks and stuff like that which
is also very fun I find in a way that
it's very similar to doodling uh you
just put your pen to paper and start
working on stuff and think of things
that uh you want to do along the way um
and that's just really fun so for the
start of this build I decided to reroute
the real Road a little bit um because we
want the real road to kind of curve
around some neighborhoods and uh come a
bit closer to the city center I think
realistically um you have like a few
blocks between the train station and the
old historic City Center so that's kind
of what we have here um we have a curvy
Road um the one you can see in the
middle of the screen here and um
alongside that you see the little path
in a sort of triangle shape my head
Cannon for this is that this is one of
the old you know star-shaped City walls
that would have been along IDE the edges
of the historic City Center and most of
it is gone at this point we don't really
have any City walls anymore um but most
uh really old cities still have a layout
around the city center where you can
tell that there used to be a city wall
and maybe some of the areas have been
turned into parks and others have become
residential but you can still kind of
see the shape a little bit and that's
also what I tried doing here you know on
two sides this city center is of course
flanked by uh the water so we don't
really need to think about defenses too
much there uh but on the other side this
this round Road over here is basically
where the old city wall would have been
and we still have some parks uh
alongside the edges uh left in there uh
but toward the train station we just
have one straight road uh which is
something that you'll very typically
find uh in the 19th century for All
European countries is that you get these
large city blocks built in the 19th
century to go straight from the uh
station to the old historic Center and
they usually also kind of a little bit
of a a showoff area you have this kind
of fancy architecture to welcome people
into the the city at some point in time
when real roads were still the major way
to to get into cities nowadays of course
it's usually highways and speaking of
which here's my attempt to try and make
some Junctions uh please excuse my
inaptitude at some points this is
literally my first time making Highway
Junctions in City skylines 2 and one
thing I have to say which I don't think
I've said enough in the video so far the
road system has to be one of the biggest
improvements in this game compared to
the first one it's just so satisfying to
blend different roads together make sure
you have some realistic looking
Junctions and most of all the fact that
you can have actual uh exit and entrance
ramps and actually have some FP Lanes on
the highways and very easily as well uh
especially because when you upgrade a
road you can kind of uh differentiate
where you want the upgrade to be some
wider you you of course have some roads
that are a little bit wider than some
other roads and when you replace an
older smaller Road by a wider Road uh
you can freely choose where exactly you
start to replace that so you can also
move the road a little bit to a side uh
and when you make these slip Lanes um
you can very easily blend them into your
Junctions so honestly the highway system
is really amazing really fun to work
with and it's really easy to make
Junctions that look realistic um and
yeah just make really nice interchanges
overall um something to note about that
as well while we go to some other part
of the city is that looking at the
highway system in the UK I found that a
lot of intersections are um or
interchanges rather uh are
well roundabout based either they're a
very large roundabout with the entrance
and exit ramps or they're a dog bone
into change where you kind of have two
roundabouts it's not literally a dog
bone which is what I was trying to build
right there for a second until I
realized that it wasn't quite as easy as
doing separate roundabouts which is
something that I see much more in the UK
than actual dog bone interchanges where
it's typically one roundabout kind of
shaped like a dog bone hence the name of
the uh of the junction
intersection interchange speaking of
which um little bit little vocabulary
thing I guess an intersection and a
junction are the same thing and just a a
a place where roads come together at the
same level and you have a roundabout or
traffic lights or stuff like that and an
interchange is where of course you have
highways coming together and flyovers
and stuff like that um I don't know I
guess I was talking without thinking
about it too much but anyway um you
typically find the these inter
interchanges with intersections with
roundabouts uh a lot in the UK so um
that's what I ended up going for with
well actually I think all of the
interchanges on the highways that I'm
going to build in this video it's just
an easy way to instantly make it look
very UK and speaking of roundabouts
having roundabouts absolutely everywhere
is also a very UK thing of course
they're very popular in other European
countries as well um but I've really
noticed that especially around highways
and newer developments you just find
these arterial roads with roundabout
after roundabout and it just uh looks
pretty UK to uh copy that whole feeling
anyway this is where the highway
connects to this city center uh so
that's a pretty important Road and then
between the highway uh and the railroad
here we have some commercial development
and a little bit of residential as well
looking at the general layouts of UK
cities find that there are many patches
of commercial development around
residential development it's a little
bit more random than say the Netherlands
for instance where you find these very
large commercial areas especially around
uh highways and they're very well
separated from residential area it's a
little bit more mixed in the UK I found
um so that's something that you'll also
find you'll find me at some small
commercial sections with very light
industry here and there uh sket between
the residential areas and speaking of
which there are a bunch of different
Urban Fabrics that inspired me for
different parts of this build so first
of all of course we have the city center
here uh on the right here uh which is
very messy lots of random roads
everywhere has a bit of a circular
layout because of course it would have
had a circular is wall around it in
medieval times and beside from that just
lots of little bendy roads um something
that's also relevant about this location
is that I built this extra little Canal
here um which wasn't there in the map
originally uh but originally I felt that
the uh there wasn't really a good place
to start a city uh most cities start
around some kind of River or the sea uh
a body of water in any case and the
river here is very much on the edge of
the map so you can't really uh build the
city all around it so I decided to add
this extra branch of the river where you
know realistically this is some kind of
Delta area so I think it's it's
realistic to have this River Branch off
into two parts around here um so we have
a bit of a nicer Historical Center for
the uh City to grow out of so yeah
that's the first kind of neighborhood uh
then we also get these 19th century
expansions which I already built a few
of just now uh which have much more
straight roads and lots of row houses or
as some in the comments of the first or
the second video said correctly uh
they're called terrorist houses in the
UK um something I always have to get
used to it's like the kind of thing that
I do know somewhere but I'm just much
more used to saying row houses and I
guess that's because it's also the
literal translation of the word in Dutch
uh but yeah it's very fair uh they're
terrorist houses um and originally the
fact that we have uh roow houses in the
game at this point is um what kind of
inspired me to do this English build in
the first place because I figured we
could finally do some victorian-esque
19th century British
neighborhoods um unfortunately the roow
houses don't quite look like that um but
it's close and I think you can uh sort
of imitate the look as well uh but the
other thing about it is that the demand
for them is just not there and this is
something that I actually had a
discussion about with some friends
recently
um personally I feel like row houses or
terrorist houses for the reckon I'm just
going to stick to row houses from this
point onward because it feels more
natural to me um but do know what I'm
talking about um I just feel like in
general that type of housing is low
density and maybe it's because I'm from
the Netherlands and it's just we view
any kind of house where you own the land
that your house is built on and you have
a little bit of land around it uh as low
dens it and personally I would see it
this way um I think all kinds of row
houses semi detached and detached
especially of course too are low density
residential and then medium density
residential would be um apartment
buildings without elevators you know uh
a Max of four floors maybe five um not
super big but uh not super small either
or some streets where you have a couple
of Apartments per building stuff like
this I think Amsterdam for instance is
medium density it doesn't have
skyscrapers it doesn't have big
apartment blocks uh but it does have
buildings of four to five floors where
each floor has a has a separate
apartment um so personally I would think
that's kind of medium density and then
high density of course is larger
apartment blocks and stuff like that so
I don't know I'm kind of in a little bit
of a disagreement with the game I think
it's understandable that the roow houses
in the game are medium density
especially if if I think about Finland
uh where the creators are from I don't
think roow houses are very common in
Finland and if they do exist they're
more around City centers and older parts
of cities generally looking at Finnish
cities you can find some denish City
centers but around that uh lots of
detached and semi detached neighborhoods
so I think that's fair and especially if
you're looking at it from an American
perspective then row houses are very
rare to see and you mostly see them in
maybe the Brownstone buildings of New
York and places like that Boston I know
has them um but then it also definitely
feels like medium density for uh the US
and the US lacks in medium density in
general which is a big issue um but yeah
overall All Things Considered I
personally feel like Rouses are low
density but unfortunately the game
doesn't agree with me and this means
that I wanted to Zone all of these um
well these are the Victorian um
neighborhoods with their long straight
roads and they're very close together so
you get some small gardens in between
but not that much space and ideally
these would have all been row houses but
unfortunately because the row houses
count to medium density demand and
there's not that much of it um I'm going
to have to Zone a lot of this as low
density so I don't know if this is a a
huge complaint uh at the game because
personally I kind of trust that once the
game is released and we get mods we're
GNA get some kind of ploppable Rico or
demand master or
whatever it is it's going to get modded
and we're going to plop buildings and
cities are going to look very different
from the way they're looking right now
in this vanilla uh unreleased build um
but still it's something uh that I have
to keep in mind right now anyway moving
on to a different area and to actually
talk about what I'm doing again um I
always kept this area reserved for uh
industrial stuff and mainly the harbor
uh because this this would would be a
port city so that's uh what we're
shaping out here and the natural
landscape already kind of had this this
sort of shape so I figured it was the
right fit to do this with and um yeah
it's just going to be one big Industrial
Area Industrial Area something I noticed
is that cargo trains have become more
relevant in this game compared to the
first game um but honestly I didn't even
think of that personally uh the
importance of using cargo trains to move
your stuff around in this game I uh just
think any realistic Industrial Area
especially if you've got a larger one uh
it just needs uh a cargo train station
um because for heavy industry rail is
really important to move your goods
around uh trucks are fine for retail and
stuff like that but heavy industry just
needs real um so realistically you want
to have some kind of connection anyway
um and in this case my connection is
actually pretty professional
I think if you look at most industrial
areas The Reel isn't quite as you know
fancy as passenger reel is it'll
typically have lots of level Crossings
and just look a bit wonky um but yeah uh
this was a pretty clean connection to
make to The Rail lines and then on the
other side where this rail is eventually
going to continue we have one of the
first things I built in this episode
which is um the big uh real yard over
there which I also think is a a
realistic area for a rail yard usually a
rail yard is pretty close to the Central
Station uh somewhere around the
outskirts of the Town though uh and in
this case it's right between the
outskirts of the town uh the city center
and uh the harbor here um so I think
it's the right location and then all of
the trains can go from the harbor to the
RO yard get sorted and uh move on and um
aside from that I also figured the
harbor was a good place to put lots of
big industrial buildings that I still
want to have anyway uh so there's the
the garbage burner building uh which is
um huge absolutely massive which I'm
very happy with uh one of the things
which always kind of irked me about City
skylines 1 is that surface buildings
were just so small and for a building
like this it just needs to be big to be
realistic um so it just makes it look
more realistic but it also means it's a
little bit more of a challenge to fit
these services in and you can't just
plop them down anywhere you want
whenever you want them uh you really
have to think about the sort of uh
spatial planning aspect of putting a
building like this in your city uh which
I think is very
nice the one thing I do kind of miss
about this though is we have to think
about how to connect this building to
the grid uh because as you can see it is
going to power the city because we're
going to burn our waste and then
generate some electricity so we do need
a a high voltage connection um but those
power lines are still pretty flexible
you can infinitely connect a number of
power lines and stuff like that and
that's just not quite realistic I do
really appreciate what they did with the
game with having these Transformer
stations be necessary to connect high to
low voltage which is very realistic uh
but also a fun gameplay element so
really good combination of both of these
aspects of making a city building game
um but at the same time connecting power
lines the way that you can in this game
is just a little bit too flexible and a
little bit too easy I get why they went
with it because you don't want to be
building substations everywhere um but
in real life uh it's very common to find
them along the routes of high voltage
lines and at some point near the end of
this episode I'm still going to build an
extra substation somewhere to really
make it look like these different high
voltage lines are connecting through a
little Hub uh which is realistically
what you want when you're um making this
kind of infrastructure
it's uh something to also think about a
lot in real life um at least personally
I don't talk about this that much uh but
I work as a policy advisor uh for
sustainability in a small town in the
Netherlands in the urban planning
department and one of the biggest
challenges that the country but also the
region and well basically every level of
government is going through not just in
the Netherlands but I imagine everywhere
in the western world right now is the h
huge challenge of making the grid um
adapt to our new energy situation uh
traditionally uh the grid more or less
Works in a way that you have a generator
somewhere be it nuclear or fossil fuel
powered um and that's just uh you know
where all of the electricity comes from
and then you just have to transport it
to the people who want it it's a very
one-way system uh but now that we're
making the energy transition from uh
fossil fuels to Renewables uh very
slowly but surely um we start to move
toward a very different uh grid uh where
there's power generation uh and demand
happening everywhere and at different
times depending on the weather and
whatever activities people are up to and
you need a system that's much more
robust but also uh has this kind of
option for two-way traffic everywhere um
so lots of uh National Grids have to be
expanded um and the same goes for the
Netherlands I know a a bunch of lines
across the country are already almost at
their Max U but even locally uh lots of
neighborhoods once enough people start
putting solar panels on their houses um
at some points on sunny days they're
just going to have to uh actually cut
down the power on the solar panels and
stop them from producing because there's
just no grit space to transport it on
anymore so huge challenges to face in
real life something we don't have to
worry about too much in City Sky lines I
think but I'm not sure uh and that's
something I'm actually curious about
when we get to much bigger cities
whether those power lines uh will be
enough or whether you need to double up
on your power lines and cut through
neighborhoods to create a new power line
uh which is realistically what's going
to have to happen in the real world uh
at some point uh but not just that we
need lots of extra small low voltage
Transformer stations in many
neighborhoods um but yeah I'm I'm
getting a bit sidetracked by this topic
I just think it's one of the most
interesting topics in terms of urban
planning that you don't find that much
in a city Builder games like this but
I'm already hugely impressed that we
have Transformers to begin with and we
have to think about how we transport the
electricity a little bit better than in
the first
game but on the other hand we can import
electricity as well so I'm not too
concerned about my power generation uh
think that's probably fine anyway anyway
um moving into this area of the city I
wanted to add an extra small Highway
around here um it's not as big as the
other highway it's just a a highway with
without a median in the middle and
something I really like is that with the
new slip Lanes we can actually create uh
interchanges with these highways as well
uh which is something that I kind of
missed in City skylines 1 and it's very
easy to do this in this game so you can
really make some local highways as well
which you don't need to move too much
traffic on but you still don't want
level Crossings on um which I think is
quite nice these kinds of Highways could
do very well in rural areas where you
still want uh one hight traffic Road um
so really cool to see uh really fun to
work with as
well anyway moving into this part of the
town uh we start to leave some of the
older 19th century expansions of the
city behind and start to move into some
more 20th 20th Century style expansions
um which at least from my uh bit of
Google Maps research and just looking
around are a little bit more planned
more curvy neighborhoods but they still
really follow the previous rural
landscape so for a lot of these areas
I'm trying to build some roads first
that look like they could have been you
know connecting roads between the uh the
farm Fields Back in the day and then try
to fill uh the gaps in between in with
uh lots of Bendy roads and
well a generally planned looking
structure and then once it's all in
place uh start building the houses uh
there are also lots of parks in between
something I noticed about UK cities is
that from above they tend to look very
clustered you really have some clusters
of residential areas uh with in between
still some green areas and really it
looks like partly still the uh the rural
landscape is intact in some places with
some of the parks looking more like
grossy fields with rows of trees around
it and really still following the shape
of the Old Farm fields that used to be
in place back in the day and sometimes
Parks uh but this is typical for English
Gardens in general really just kind of
mimic the natural landscape uh if you
consider for instance French gardening
French parks are very uh symmetrical
they're all about shapes uh and geometry
so you have all of these hedges in
straight patterns and stuff like that
looks very fancy uh but English parks
and Gardens are very much about trying
to recreate the traditional English
landscape with lots of grass and uh some
tree lines and stuff like that uh which
I think you know they both have their
merits but I really like the English
approach it looks a little bit more
natural and this even goes for I think
some parks inside the cities and suburbs
uh which is quite nice uh so even though
they suburbs some of them still have a
kind of rural or rurban some people
would say say uh look to them which I
quite like um but yeah that's about that
uh then there's the fact that all of
these bendy roads don't really result in
the best um functioning residential
areas in the sense that there will be
all kinds of gaps between the houses but
I think that's also fine I recently had
a friend ask me if the curvy roads are a
bit more doable in this game compared to
the first one and I think because the
zoning system works exactly the same
it's not really uh gotten any better it
also hasn't gotten any worse I think uh
to make a realistic City Center we're
just going to need some kind of plopping
mod because it's just not going to
happen uh with a game like this you know
you can't have your buildings connect if
they're on a curve you get all of these
gaps in between which is it makes sense
I think it would be very difficult to uh
figure out another way to do it um but
yeah I think it works fine for suburbs
like this in fact I might actually
prefer it because you get some gaps in
between between where you can plant
trees and just make the neighborhood
more green uh so I think it works here I
think that just in City centers it's a
little bit more annoying uh one thing I
did notice about the the zoning next to
curvy roads is that it does spawn into
reasonable shapes I think uh for some of
these curves you can tell that some
weird shapes ended up happening but for
most of them I think the whatever
algorithm is behind this comes up with
reasonable shapes where you don't get
very small plots of land but you still
have some good decent sized uh zonab
areas so you can actually get some nice
buildings alongside curvy roads and if
you make your road just a little bit
curvy um you don't actually get too many
issues with all kinds of different
clustered uh grids um you can actually
have one whole section of zable land in
a single grid next to a very slightly
curvy road so making your roads very
slightly curvy as you you'll often see
in the UK is more or less fine you won't
run into too many issues there something
to also note is that these 19th and 20th
Century uh neighborhoods kind of follow
the railroad instead of the other way
around but you might still have some
older roads going through these areas
that continue on both sides of the
railroad um because they would have
already been there before real was there
so this is really uh an area where you
kind of have to think a little bit of
like what kind of Roads are already
centuries old and going through Farm
Fields these need to kind of uh you know
be cut through by real um and then
between that the newer developments are
kind of filled in uh within that uh and
you don't really have a real line
cutting straight through a 19th century
uh expansion for instance it'll usually
actually be built alongside the real so
you know you can try to build uh in one
go as if the city has grown or
organically if you keep things like this
in mind but still I do find it's a
little bit easier and maybe even a
little bit more fun uh perhaps to watch
as well uh to do it the realistic way
but it's just going to take so much more
time especially because you're doing a
lot of work that you're undoing at some
later stage and really trying to
visualize the growth of a city over time
and uh ain't nobody got time for that at
least not right now uh also I decided to
make the real line a little bit weirdly
shaped like that over there uh um just
because we're out of space on the map
but I didn't want to weirdly cut the
rail Over The Interchange over there so
it is what it is and then over here I
decided I also wanted an exit uh an
entry ramp uh for this little local
Highway as well um which also works uh
better than I expected I guess this
would be a half a clover leaf uh kind of
with two roundabouts on the side but
it's still a a nice kind of intersection
I I'm not sure if I've seen too many of
these in the UK it feels a little bit
more Dutch it's uh it's something you
very typically find in the
Netherlands um but it doesn't matter too
much and I think it's the only thing
that fits here because otherwise the uh
it would be too close to the big
roundabout interchange over there um so
yeah we just have to do it also I
decided to add some tree lines alongside
all of the highways and the exits and
also some of the real lines um it's just
something that you find in a lot of
English cities not just the rural
landscape is filled with tree lines but
also the cities alongside all kind of uh
infrastructure and I guess it's an easy
decision to make whenever you're
building some kind of large
infrastructure to just plant trees
alongside the whole thing um plus it
serves a function as well of course it's
a it's a sound barrier a very natural
sound barrier um so we like to have
these things uh also another thing
that's worth noting is that I switched
to a new version of the game at some
point in the middle of this video um I
did only start working on this video
when we got the newest build of the game
at the time when we could start uh
working on the third video uh but
somewhere through the middle of that
process uh a few days ago a new update
was released with Seasons uh which is
super exciting so you suddenly see it
becoming autumn in this video here and
the next we'll move into winter and
everything's going to look dark for a
little bit uh but once spring and summer
comes around you can really see the
lighting change as well um and I think
Autumn looks amazing I'm really happy
with this change actually uh really
positively surprised by how the trees
look and just in general how much the
overall Vibe and lighting of the Maps
change depending on the season uh really
cool to see so overall I don't think I
have too much to add about that uh just
the fact that it's unfortunately a
little hard to see exactly how these
changes affect the city um because all
the trees that I'm planting right now
and you know making all these tree lines
and filling in some of the gaps between
different parts of the city with some
forest all of those saplings still need
to
grow something else I noticed actually
and that you don't get to see too much
in this video but you've probably seen
it in the Cinematic in the beginning uh
trees die in this game as well and once
they die they leave a seing behind that
starts growing in their place again and
I'm not entirely sure how much I like
like this uh I think it's cool that they
have this realistic Dynamic going on and
it's also nice because the age that
trees get is kind of random you know
there's probably some kind of normal
deviation to it but in any case I
noticed that all of my tree lines on the
main island have already died a few
times and started growing again and it
makes it so that different trees are in
different phases of their growth and it
just makes the whole thing look a lot
more uh natural so that's nice uh but it
does happen very often so almost half of
my tree lines are either dead or tiny
saplings at any point in time um and I
don't know I kind of wish we could
extend the life of a tree a little bit
because it does feel to me a little bit
real unrealistic in a sense that they
die very quickly uh and then a new one
starts growing already um but it does
result in some pretty nice forests and
tree lines I think it's a it's a real
realistic touch that they added this so
overall I'm pretty happy with it uh but
it's definitely something I started
noticing in my older areas uh can
sometimes make things look a little bit
funky also I just realized that the
interchange that I've been talking about
the whole time uh isn't a darkk bone but
a dumbbell interchange um which I guess
is fair it kind of does look like a
dumbbell but uh little bit different as
well so something along those lines also
at this point I started thinking about
my uh electricity Network and my power
lines and how I was going to move power
around the city eventually I decided
that I did want some areas to look like
a power line is really cutting through
an area um and we have these you know
these kind of park-like Landscapes
underneath the power lines um and they
just cut through neighborhoods and stuff
like that which realistically you do
want this to happen um there's something
about really high voltage power lines
that they're much more expensive and
difficult to put underground than lower
voltage power lines so even in the
Netherlands where most power lines are
underground at this point uh this is
only up to a certain voltage I think
something like 150 to 220 Kilt is still
doable to put underground um but the
main network of 380 kilovolts is just
completely
undoable um or at least not practical I
know in the Netherlands there's one
section where they put this very high
voltage power line underground uh but
it's tremendously expensive and also
quite difficult in terms of Maintenance
uh it's just the higher up you go in
voltage the more
insulation you need and everything and
it just becomes harder progressively
depending on the voltage to put these
lines underground so um to summarize
it's generally a reason why I still
wanted above ground power lines to
actually go through the city and come up
with a way to make them realistically
you know uh go through it another thing
to keep in mind is that you can very
very easily make very curvy power lines
in the game uh but in real life it's
much more typical to see power lines
with very large straight sections uh
because curves are not very easy to do
on power lines and you don't want to add
too many of them in any given line uh
because you need special pylons for it
and they're a little bit uh more uh
labor and resource intensive um and it
just looks a bit more realistic if your
power lines are very straight for large
sections and then curve in certain parts
um and I've also built this kind of
super station here in the bottom left
where a bunch of power lines come
together uh split off uh one goes to St
Luke one goes to the garbage incinerator
and then one goes to the outside
connection um so I think that's a decent
electricity Network I really couldn't
think of a way to connect the power line
on the other side of the city so I think
I'm just going to have um a power
station on the other side of the city
and then just connect to the low voltage
Network inside the city and I think
that's fine I don't think you need uh
two out outside connections per se at
least with this one outside connection
um or well I do have two outside
connections but they don't need to be uh
connected basically to each other uh if
they both feed the city and if we have
our main electricity producer hooked up
to uh the city itself I think we'll be
fine in terms of our power Network it
just means that I don't have to have a
weird power line cut through the city's
Center and um at some point in the
future future I think it would make
sense to have the power line kind of cut
uh around the city uh if you look at
maps of power lines you'll typically
find that uh just like highways they
they'll often have some rings around big
cities uh because they do need to feed
the big cities uh but you don't want the
power lines go straight through them uh
and putting them underground is for the
aforementioned reasons not very doable
all the time either um so yeah that's
always a realistic option for later as
well and anyway at this point of the
video I was realizing that I was already
recording for a very long time and
didn't really have a completely uh
realistic and finished section of the
map uh done um so that's a little bit of
an oof uh but at the same time I think I
just wanted to uh finish as much as I
could and especially around this area
fill in some of the gaps that were still
left unfortunately some fields are still
going to be empty because as you can see
I keep building low residential uh but I
also keep having low residential demand
and every time I add extra low
residential it fills up and it fills in
some of the older high density
residential and Commercial zones and
Industrial zones that I already built um
but then we just have to keep on going
and still the city center wasn't you
know filled in to the extent which I
would like it to be and you still have
all of these uh areas which are zoned as
roow houses uh which is still not
getting built because the demand for it
is just not there so it is what it is
I'm going to have to keep building for
much longer than I could fit into this
one video to actually have enough um low
density residential to make the high
density uh residential and Commercial
City Center um so that that's there's
just no other way to do that um so you
know even if I don't like it that much
there was no way that I was going to
finish this city to the extent that I
wanted to in this video because it's
just going to take way too much low low
density residential to make as large and
dense of a city center uh that I'm
planning right here also at this point I
figured it was time to add the
university which I think it looks a
little bit more like an American
University because it's got all of these
large gardens around it and it's a big
fancy building like this I think UK
universities tend to be a little bit
more in the city center and a little bit
more connected to different buildings
around them um which makes sense um but
but yeah it is what it is I think I just
wanted to have a university somewhere so
I just ended up using the American kind
of layout in the end with a big main
University building and then some other
faculty buildings around it uh kind of
look um but yeah it definitely does look
a bit American I think also I decided to
put it on the hill here so at least we
have some nice buildings uh to see in
the distance when we look at the city
from uh the ground so that's pretty cool
and around it we have some some of the
most expensive and Chic neighborhoods of
the city so very loose Urban fabric lots
of squiggly roads lots of large houses
and uh a separate train station as well
and that's the last neighborhood that I
decided to work on for this video so I'd
like to thank you guys for watching and
I'll leave you with some cinematic shots
and hopefully I'll see you in the next
one where we are going to finish the
city see
you
[Music]